Arsen to his 350 miles swim the
endurance swimmer stopped at Hayling
Island in Hampshire where he met our
science correspondent Thomas More look
it's quite like her CD rack or something
boy stirs not for eating but for saving
the Seas Lewis Pugh is swimming the
length of the English Channel to raise
awareness of poor marine protection
oysters have been overfished in the
Solent for decades and now their future
depends on breeding stock suspended in
cages in the water we think that the
seas are bountiful we think that they
can rejuvenate themselves we think that
we can take out more and more and more
and more but we can't and eventually it
does catch up with us
our oceans now are on the verge of
bankruptcy I've been swimming for 30
years and I have seen them going from
healthy and bountiful to 15 million
oysters being caught here where I grew
up as a young boy it's a completely
collapsing 23,000 doses are dangling
beneath pontoons in ten locations around
the Solent in a project funded by the
blue marine foundation a generation ago
15 million oysters a year were harvested
from these waters but the fishery was
closed five years ago because there was
so few left each one of these oysters
will produce at around a million larvae
every year which will be swept by the
tides of round the Solent that's really
good for the environment obviously but
also for the fishing industry which is
heavily behind this project because it
means there will be Easter's to be
harvested by future generations
Lewis is swimming through a sea that's
given minimal protection less than three
square miles of UK coastal waters have a
complete fishing ban other species could
go the same way as the oyster there are
loads and loads of species around the
British coast but nobody is looking at
and we are extremely concerned about
look at the Welk look at the cuttlefish
these are these are species that you
catch in the English Channel and neither
River looking too clever and
nobody is managing you Luis is drumming
up support for his campaign as he heads
towards Dover the long swim isn't just
about an epic human challenge but poor
marine protection on our coastline
Thomas More Sky News Portsmouth